Build it. Draw It. Play It.
Vsauce! This is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build it.
Pinokio is a robotic creation created by students
from Victoria University of Wellingtonby
modifying a lamp and adding animatronic elements.
Its actions are driven primarily by Arduino
and image processing software OpenCV, which
searches for faces with its webcam, once it
finds a face it attempts to follow it as if
trying to maintain eye contact.
Theo Jansens latest miniature kinetic sculpture
is called the Animaris Geneticus Ondularis.
It walks on 20 separate legs that move in
a fluid wavelike sequence. It incorporates
122 moving parts and is produced by the on
demand 3D printing service Shapeways.
"Box" is an ongoing series of unusual photos
from Belgium based 354 Photographers. Crafted
out of cardboard and filled with miniature
furniture each diorama was built around the
perspective of the camera to ensure the scenes
had the right angle and depth. Photos of the
human subjects were then added using photoshop.
The creators describe the scenes as a little
depressing and a little funny but they want
the viewers to do the interpreting for themselves.
The bird buggy was created by University of
Florida engineering student Andrew Gray to
keep his parrot occupied and quiet. The vehicle
is controlled by a joystick that the bird
can move in four directions with it's beak
and is also equipped with bump sensors and
infrared collision sensors to keep the bird
from getting stuck. Once the bird is removed
the bird buggy returns itself to a docking
station utilizing a web camera.
Draw It
Medical illustrator Emily Evans created a
set of Histology plates with the help of her
colleagues in the medical and art fields.
She was provided with prepared slides of various
stained and scanned human tissues and worked
with a ceramic artist to make the plates.
They are 20 cm bone china cake plates and
come in 8 different human tissue designs,
Thyroid, Bowel, Liver, Bone, Pancreas, Oesophagus,
Kidney and Testicle.
99 Steps of progress is a series of illustrations
that parody the famous march of progress created
by Paris artist collective, Maentis. A new
illustration is unveiled each day for 99 days
and each design is available for purchase
in a variety of formats including prints,
posters, tshits & hoodies. Check out the website
for the latest edition.
And now for the gadgets with guts artwork
of Mad Peitersen...
GIFF-ITI is digitally animated street art
created by UK artist INSA. He paints, takes
a photo, and repaints multiple times to create
motion and then brings it to the internet
as an animated GIFF.
Play it
Volume and Noise is an interactive social
media project by Sean Hathaways that consists
of a 30's Philco radio modified to speak tweets
in real time...
ZIC ZAZOU is a group of musicians from France
that make music using everyday objects. Here
they are playing "Habanera" from the classic
Opera Carmen...
Engineering student James McVay built MechBass,
a robotic bass guitar that consists of four
string units on an aluminum frame. Here it
is playing "Hysteria" by muse.
Rap Rave is the newest track from West London
Emcee Scrufizzer directed by John Moore with
illustrations by Hattie Stewart.
Submit your BiDiPis as a person message here
on youtube - or share them with everyone over
at the new Vsauce2 facebook page.
Click here to listen to bidipi radio. Music
created and submitted by you guys. Also check
out Your BiDiPi - an entire video dedicated
to your creations. And as always... thanks
for watching.